the author of the captain which is
available wherever you get your books
right now the memoir from the last mets
captain and a beloved figure in new york
city
david wright here on the show how are
you david
hi rich thanks for having me you bet
what do you think of the expanded
playoffs that we're seeing
right now i think i i respectfully
obviously
uh disagree maybe with you i think that
during my career you know it was so hard
to make the playoffs in baseball
and i don't know if there's a right or
wrong but you know i treasured the few
playoff appearances i got and i couldn't
imagine being a
you know a 500 or a sub 500 team you
know and making the playoffs so i think
that it's a little more special than
you know being a 500 team and making the
playoffs but you know what do i know
no but i mean you you i don't know i
mean you you
we saw i guess although it was a full
season but we we've heard of teams like
the nationals or
the st louis cardinals for instance in
recent days go from a 500 team middle of
the season then all of a sudden they go
on a
a tear and a run maybe maybe that could
happen i mean
we have seen six seeds in the nfl one at
all and i don't think anybody
sees it tarnished i i i don't i i kind
of don't mind it
but then again i i i wasn't a
professional baseball player
you know i'm with you there because in
in 06
we went to the playoffs and i believe we
had the best record in national league
and we lost to the cardinals in game
seven of the nfcs
who everybody was saying back their way
into the playoffs
to get there and then all of a sudden
they get hot and um
you know in october and they win the
world series so i'm with you there
okay so uh when did you first hear i
mean where were you when you first heard
the mets took you and that you were
going to be a new york met
david when did that happen you know
that's it's funny it was uh i was in
my senior year of high school in hickory
high in chesapeake virginia
and i had an anatomy and physiology exam
we were still in school
on the draft and i had to take my exam
my final exam so i'm rushing home
i had my dad and some family members and
some close friends over the house and at
the time it was the aol
dial up you know and that's the only way
you could hear your name
being called or drafted you know for the
major league draft so
you know this thing is like making funny
sounds and we can barely hear the audio
and um you know i made it home after the
first round and i could kind of see that
my name had been called by the looks on
my parents and my friends faces and then
you know 38th overall the mets have the
pick
and you know they announced my name and
it's just you know craziness in the
house because our
aaa affiliate the norfolk tides was 15
minutes from where i grew up so we used
to go to the
the triple-a affiliate the norfolk tides
games all the time so i grew up a
displaced mets fan in southeast virginia
so it was a dream come true for me now
look uh i know you're
you're you're not just a captain because
of how um you played the game but
because of your um your comportment your
your heart and your leadership skills
that said
the minute you heard you were drafted
you said screw that test right you
didn't take that test
i finished the test i did pretty well on
them uh but no that
my parents uh my my father was a police
officer my mother worked in the school
system so it was like
okay you know forget about the draft you
got to do good on this test task
baseball is never going to work out you
know baseball's never going to work out
you got to have a plan b you can't put
all your eggs in that basket so you
better be a good student so
uh you know school was always first in
my household i know i
mean and it isn't first in mind too but
i mean uh
you know uh senioritis certainly sets in
when the new york mets draft you right i
mean that's got to set in
certainly when the met's coming off of a
world series appearance against the
yankees
i mean that's it it was pretty cool
going to school the next day
after your first round draft pick of the
new york mets
that was cool going to school the next
day for sure all right uh david right
here on the rich housing show toughest
pitcher you ever had to face
was oh that's a great it probably
depends on kind of which
time of my career when i first got
caught up john smoltz owned me
could never see a slider then the
phillies traded for roy halliday
and that was i might as well not even
bring a bat up there and he knew it too
jose fernandez uh was
impossible for me uh craig kimbrell the
closer for the braves
those are guys that just absolutely own
me now who did you own
let's be honest who did you like i i got
this guy who's that i'd like to think if
you were a lefty
you didn't have much of a shot because i
for some reason i saw
lefties pretty good um one of the
interesting ones
was uh brad penny for whatever reason i
saw him well too
and uh had had great numbers against
brad penney
uh david right here on the rich hazard
show did you ever meet sever did you
ever meet tom
i know that the mets and tom didn't have
that great of a relationship sometimes
but did you ever meet the
the late great tom seaver david so the
franchise was around a lot when i was a
younger player i love it and i developed
a nice
rap and a friendship with with mr seaver
for whatever reason he kind of
he saw something in me and wanted to
mentor me
and i'd get a call you know once a month
once every six weeks
from this receiver and we'd talk about
everything except baseball he wanted to
know what i was doing away from the
field what i was doing to occupy my time
what i was doing to take my mind away
from the failures of baseball
and that helped me out tremendously and
one of my biggest regrets
was uh he ran a vineyard up in in
northern california up in napa
and he invited me up there numerous
times and he said if you come
i'm going to put you to work i got a
pair of boots for you and i never took
them off on it and
i certainly wish i had i bet but how
cool is that though
that you're you're you're a young kid
trying to make your bones new york city
obviously you know the yankees when you
were coming up uh
with a former met and met manager and
joe torre winning all these world series
you're trying to make your bones and tom
seaver says
uh takes a liking to you that is amazing
that is so cool you gotta love that
unbelievably i mean it's it's as good as
you
just said it times it you know by 100 it
was so cool having
you know the the one of the best players
to ever put a uniform on
uh to kind of take you under his wing
and want to teach you about not just
baseball but life
so what's your favorite moment as a met
david give it give it to me
what was it 2015 world series uh you
know i mentioned earlier i grew up in in
southeast virginia
and um you know out in the backyard with
with my dad and my grandfather and
you know they had this big old wooded
bat that they taught me how to
you know play baseball with with a
wiffle ball and and you know being met
fans my dad read about greg jeffrey's
taking swings underwater with a wooden
bat so he throws me in my grandfather's
pool and i'm taking swings underwater
with the
and you know we're in the backyard and
it's you know world series here comes
the pitch
whack home run and and you know fast
forward to 2015 i got that opportunity
to live out the dream and
win a pennant um a national league
pennant for the new york mets
um you know go to the world series and
ultimately we lost it but
you know to hit a home run in the world
series and to you know wear that world
series patch on your shoulder and your
hat
uh for me was a dream come true there's
i'm biased i'm from staten island
i am a yankee fan in full disclosure
nobody's perfect
[Laughter]
well david we know uh deep down in your
memoir was excised from the book as you
wish you were yankee
that's true right that that that chapter
got that that got edited out
not quite okay not quite no but in uh i
am biased
uh there's nothing like the the cheer of
a new york crowd there's nothing like it
there's a certain
roar there's a certain i don't know what
it is a timber to it
there's nothing like it for me nothing
for me growing up question and
and and you know i don't tend to give
yankees or yankee fans credit but the
roll call is pretty special and
uh you know some of my favorite games
regular season games where
you know as much as we try to play it
down yes you know the subway series
means nothing you know it's just another
game
oh that's nice it was always really cool
to go into the old yankee stadium or the
new yankee stadium
um you know hopefully win but to be you
know there for
roll call and you know some of the cool
antics that they got out there in the
bleachers well i wasn't just referring
yankee fans i'm referring to met fans
too we were recounted the other day it
was the 19-year anniversary of piazza
hitting the home run in the first game
back in new york city i i
imagine that was just freshly after you
were drafted by the mets
just that moment just hearing the fans
in the crowd uh
in what it meant to the city it just
brought me to tears just thinking about
it david
just i mean and i know you weren't there
yet but you could just knew
you just knew what the mets uh could do
for the city
uh right then and there and then you
showed up pretty much not too far behind
right as a speaking as a mets fan that
was my favorite
moment no question was the piazza home
run uh after 9 11.
it meant so damn much so what what
should people uh
know about your memoir the captain a
memoir david
what do you want people to know about
that it was fun because you know i never
in my wildest dreams would i think that
i would write a book or there'd be a
book written about me
um you know but when i was approached to
do this project
as an athlete i don't think you get the
opportunity
to kind of live in the moment and kind
of enjoy what you're doing
while you're doing it you're always
looking forward to that next challenge
or you're worried about
john smoltz or roy holiday pitching the
next night you're trying to prepare for
that
so getting a chance to kind of relive
some of these great
lifelong memories that i'm gonna have on
a baseball field and
you know watch the video and replays and
you know talk about
you know different perspectives and what
you were thinking at the time
was really cool for me to be able to
kind of go back and
and cherish those moments and you know a
quick funny story is i got a chance to
pick out like 30
personal pictures for the middle of the
book and um
you know my parents are on the east
coast we live out on the west coast now
and i asked my dad can you send me some
childhood pictures i want to go through
and pick some so i get like four huge
fedex boxes on my doorstep and going
through those pictures of
you know me as a baby or me holding a
bat for the first time and
you know me with with family and amateur
baseball and minor leagues and even when
i was in the big leagues you know my mom
coming down to the
deck circle and taking a picture with
her camera you know like hey david it's
your mother turn around and say cheese
you know it was some of that stuff
really brought a big smile to my face
and really enjoyed kind of reminiscing
and going through everything
you know good and bad at my career well
david i've got a diehard met fan uh
wearing a met hat your jersey is to his
left he's in charge of our social media
he's
tj jefferson the name of the show is the
rich eisen show there is an eye in rich
and eisen but i'm a team player t.j do
you want to ask david a question
your favorite mets of what's up cap
i appreciate that hey tj so new
ownership steve cohen just bought the
team
um i think we're all pretty much excited
about that
my question to you is can you see
yourself making a return
front office to the field as a manager
coach i mean
you know what's what's the future
looking like can we
can we entice you to come back home put
me on the spot here i'll say this
that i don't foresee myself coaching or
managing
um you know i tried to coach my
daughter's
co-ed three and four-year-old t-ball
team this year and it didn't go well
let's put it that way um moving forward
i i love that organization
i want to be a part of it um you know if
there's some sort of part-time role
where i love
uh i got the opportunity the last couple
years go to spring training and work
with some of the younger infielders
right i really enjoyed that um
i've done a little bit of front office
stuff i've enjoyed dabbling in that so i
think i like doing a little bit of
everything not necessarily focusing on
one thing but yes i would love to
continue to be a part of the
organization
i mean one of the first moves was to
bring sandy alderson back in and you
must have a nice relationship with him
david i do one of the most respected uh
one of the most respected men in
baseball in my opinion i mean not just
because of his background
but you know what he's done in baseball
and the respect that he demands
i think um you know sandy's going to
flourish
so i am mandated to ask you in a couple
minutes i have left is why didn't it go
well with the t-ball what happened
what happened uh i i think i'm i maybe
was a tried to too disciplined i think i
was more of a tom coughlin
and i think i had to be more of a
players coach okay
i i demanded excellence from the three
and four-year-olds
and right you know when i think i showed
them up on the field a little too much
you know when they run the wrong
way on the base pass i had bad body
language and i don't think the parents
appreciated that very much so i think i
need to
take a step back take a deep breath and
maybe become an assistant coach next
week
did you get run david did you get run is
that what happened
did you get we're kind of our own umpire
sort of okay
so you know i i tried to talk a little
trash to the opposing
coaches and i don't think they like that
either so you know i'm trying to find my
balance between
you know uh you know they're three and
four and and trying to
tame the competitiveness but it was a
lot of fun and rewarding
and uh you know hopefully uh they'll
have me back next year well we all know
again uh uh you you got the gate because
uh
even with the ball on a t joe west blew
it so we know that david
we know that we know that you said it
rich you said it
all right uh before i do let you go who
do you think wins the world series
this year it's such a it's such a it's
such an easy pick
you know not easy but like it's kind of
a cowardly pick
but you know the dodgers how do you not
pick the dodgers i don't know
um that's a good one the yankees look
good
um okay last night but i'm gonna stick
with the dodgers they've been so close
for so long and i just
i really admire that organization from a
developmental
aspect and you know what they've done at
the big league level um
so i'll i'll take the dodgers david
thanks for the time congrats
on the on the book i i love this chat uh
again what you did on the new york stage
is nothing short of remarkable and uh
you have a place
in the heart of uh new york sports fans
forever
and congratulations on having that
moving forward in your life
call back i appreciate the kind words it
even means more coming from a yankee fan
you know what it's it's it it it is
heartfelt
uh but it's also buoyed by the fact that
the yankees got a ton of rings and it
makes me feel happy
you get the final word you take care
david thanks for the call
thanks for having me you got it the
captain available wherever books
are acquired the great david wright hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here